hi my name is jian and i'm 10 years old
and today i'm having two chefs compete
to make my dream dish
hello
how are you good how are you i'm good
i'm claudette and i'm katie nice to meet
you we heard that you like leprechauns i
like gold too not a girl
so what do you think a leprechaun eats
maybe like little shoe prints and like a
rainbow with gold clouds can you draw
what you imagine she's gonna have
a rainbow so she's drawing this rainbow
and i'm now thinking oh sugar sweets
cake and so i'm getting excited gotta
have dem gold clouds
he's got to have some clovers gotta stay
healthy
right you gotta eat your greens yeah
greens what is that it's like a figure
eight clover
nothing ever happened coloring color in
green means vegetables and this is my
chance to put some healthy things on the
plate when started drying the clovers i
was like this is my wheelhouse i can
cook with green stuff and then the bomb
drops do you like vegetables i don't
like carrots that's mostly it oh no she
is a picky eater what else would the
leprechaun eat besides this sounds weird
but moss moth
more greens she wants clovers and grass
but she hates all vegetables then we're
gonna have some footprints a footprint
is that like a lot of fiber like what's
uh what's a footprint what's it made out
of made of the bottom of someone's shoe
can you eat a footprint is my question
so like a rubbery texture
i have some of them gold coins
apparently the leprechaun had plenty of
gold and was trying to spread the wealth
what's your favorite meal of the day
dinner what's your favorite kind of
dinner what dinners do you like honey
chicken i don't remember being that
poise when i was a kid jenna is super
cool she is a great artist she draws so
well i'm like i'm very impressed i could
not draw that well at age 10. so thank
you so much for showing this everything
that your leprechaun would eat and we're
super excited we'll see where we go from
here with your dream dish thank you
thank you
[Music]
so here's my plan i'm going to make a
leprechaun landscape so i'm going to
make the base terrain a giant sugar
cookie i'm going to cover the terrain
with green graham cracker moss for the
shamrock i'm going to make a simple
sugar cookie dyed green the footprints
are going to be melted dark chocolate
for the coins i'm melting white
chocolate and then dusting it with gold
dust and finally for the rainbow and the
clouds i'm making marshmallow from
scratch and diet all the colors of the
rainbow i am going to go for a fully
balanced leprechaun meal i'm going to
start with a mossy base of toasted
coconut for the shamrocks i'm gonna make
green quesadillas the gold coins are
gonna be made of honey chicken
medallions i'm gonna spin some sugar
into clouds and top it off with a fruit
rainbow cheesecake
[Music]
what are you starting with what are you
doing
cookie cookie i'm gonna go 3d this is
all a cookie yeah okay so the whole
thing is basically edible yeah great
it's really impressive
i've watched every top chef season so
i'm very familiar with claudette and i'm
very intimidated by claudette i'm just
gonna make it like a simple little sugar
cookie creaming the butter and then
sugar then moving on to the flour and a
tablespoon of vanilla extract crossing
my fingers at what i think it's gonna
look like is what it's gonna look like
i'm doing my crust it's a very simple
crust we've got five graham crackers
here i'm gonna do it in the food
processor just so it gets really fine
and sticks together better so katie
tells me that she's making a no-bake
cheesecake i'd never had a no-bake
cheesecake so i was interested but
skeptical now there's no baked
cheesecake yeah riddle me that batman
because i have never actually made a
no-bake cheesecake it's popular on
pinterest i do powdered sugar and some
whipped cream so that kind of helps
stabilize it i am gonna cream this cream
cheese and then i'm gonna be adding in
so now i put in powdered sugar and some
vanilla extract and i'm putting a little
sour cream
does looking great now i need to free
form it into my terrain with peaks and
valleys i'm gonna make it mountain-esque
i am a little concerned that this is not
gonna set uh in time for the big reveal
which will be like a very runny
mess
but we're gonna just keep it in the
springform pan here you go
i just hope that she likes whatever you
know
doesn't spin anything out oh
that happened
[Music]
okay so i have my cream cheese mixture
in my springform pan and i'm gonna go
put this in the freezer and hope that it
sits
so for the clovers on the recipe i'm
going to make some clover cookies which
is basically the same sugar cookie
recipe i'm just going to half it and
color this one green i don't know why
i'm doing this the complete hard way
like i didn't bring a rolling pin oh no
let's get you a rolling pin rookie city
could you roll it in with beef berries
you want this apple cider vinegar oh you
know you know
i like you in the clutch okay so i have
my green cookie dough it'll get darker
as it bakes i hope so i'm paying
attention to her drawing to make it as
like her drawing as i can with these
shamrocks so i'm grabbing my knife and
carving out what looks like a three leaf
clover
it's really not a four-leaf clover no it
is a three weave maybe she has left with
three leaves and not four okay so the
first big part of the project is done
now we can go to rainbow so i'm gonna be
making
honey chicken for the gold coin
i'm not shaping them like coins no it's
gonna be like a gold nugget
do leprechauns collect gold nuggets
stop staring
so i'm going to make a batter for it
that'll marinate in for a bit that i
would have done with orange chicken so
far i've added flour and i've added corn
starch and i'm going to do some salt and
some pepper i'm adding an egg now
because there'll be a little bit of a
binder in there
it's gonna be a pancake kind of looking
better this coconut is for the grass i'm
gonna add some food coloring to it i'm
gonna toast it so that it's kind of like
a you know like a coconut shrimp
situation
you understand yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna
put this on this sheet oh it looks like
broccoli it's going in the f for my
marshmallow the first thing i'm doing is
blooming the gelatin this is my first
time using titanium what so is that even
meat totally backfired sheet gelatin is
named by metals so you have silver gold
bronze and titanium they have like
strengths which makes like a tougher
marshmallow or like a fluffier
marshmallow this could go either way
next i have to get my pot going with
water sugar and corn syrup and
separating my egg whites for the mixer
with a whisk attachment
[Music]
marshmallows
just basically stabilized meringue
the moss is looking a little darker than
i thought it was going to it's looking a
little creepy i'm a little worried that
it's not going to look as magical as her
drawing it's more like a graveyard now
and then an irish landscape in ireland
landscape so now i'm gonna make my shoes
i'm gonna make them with some chocolates
uh and basically i'm just gonna cut them
in sort of a shoe shape these shoes
are clunkers they are bad
they look like twix
like the leprechaun ada twigs and then
dropped it for the gold fluffy clouds at
the end of her rainbows i'm going to
scoop marshmallow into a bowl and hope
they look like a cumulus cloud the good
thing of marshmallows once it's stiff i
can actually carve it to look like a
cloud as long as i have the volume so
now i gotta do my colors
i feel like this is gonna be like a
blooper like this is when things go
south like our narrator and this is when
claudette got incredibly confident it
turned out she was wrong so i've piped
the first arch of the rainbow and that's
my pink oh it's already hardening
i got a pipe really fast i think the
colors i'm pretty confident in what i'm
not confident in is the textures it
starts going from the smooth marshmallow
to scrambled eggs real fast this looks
so gross
and this is when claudette got
incredibly confident it turns out she
was wrong
next i'm gonna be making shamrock
quesadillas fun she didn't say she likes
quesadillas
who cares kids love quesadillas right
like all kids so you can't go wrong
basically i'm gonna take these i'm gonna
make the quesadilla and then i'm gonna
cut out once it cools some shamrock
shape i have a cheese problem i love
cheese so much the quesadilla is looking
good i'm gonna let this guy cool down so
i've made one quesadilla but i need to
cut out three shamrocks and if i mess up
any of them i don't really have room to
make another so i've got to get it right
hey
oh it's falling apart
it's
he looks all right second is so much
better i'm getting better each time the
third one
doesn't look that great but it kind of
looks like it's going to give me a hug
it's got really wide
clovers leaves what are these things
now i'm gonna work on my garnishes my
coins and my footprints so i'm melting
the white chocolate over a double boiler
so i'm trying to control the temperature
the water the melt all at the same time
it's like a circus act when you're doing
chocolate your tempering chocolate you
want to seed in a hard chocolate and
that's going to basically recrystallize
it so you don't get this soft mushy
chocolate so now i'm going to spoon my
coins onto parchment
and hope that when the temperature comes
all the way down they harden and then i
can brush in with the gold now i'm going
to melt my dark chocolate and that's
going to be for my footprints i hope
she's got a lot of homework to do after
she's done with this she's going to be
amped i'm piping the pads and the little
dots it doesn't look like a traditional
footprint so i'm just winging it to what
the picture looks like i got my oil at
350 and i'm gonna put my chicken in to
fry
so now i'm gonna basically make my
my moth
with some graham crackers
[Music]
now i'm going to add in the green food
coloring into the graham cracker and
hopefully dye the whole thing green i
was a little skeptical that the dye is
going to dye it completely green but i'm
actually pleasantly surprised it does
look like moss in nature i think i won
the battle of the moss because it looks
more fluffy the way moss looks over
rocks here's my oh
the good thing is it's still warm so i'm
gonna like make actual like valleys a
little bit deeper
my next step i have some butter that i
melted and i am going to sprinkle the
moss all over the cookie
and hope that it looks like
i could see a leprechaun frolicking
through here
okay my chicken is looking good i'm
gonna take it out with my spider i know
that the honey chicken doesn't look like
coins so katie back in the day would
have made like sugar coins or chocolate
coins but i want to make what she asked
for and she loves honey and honey's kind
of golden i'm not worried about it i
want her to like what she eats so that's
all i'm focused on today is like she
likes honey chicken i'm going to add my
chicken in it doesn't look as golden and
light as i was expecting i think john is
smart enough and hopefully she's going
to understand what i was going for so
here are my clouds when i reveal the
marshmallow out of the bowl it looks
like a blob of marshmallow so i probably
should have sifted my powdered sugar
because it made like little lumps and
kind of texture i'm thinking if i can
kind of carve it if you look at big
cumulus clouds they're just kind of like
these like cotton balls stuck together
drama right we want drama we want height
she did say that these were gold so i'm
going to brush gold luster dust on it
whenever you're dealing with anything
sugar soft pliable when you lift it
there's a sort of knot in your stomach
that you get because it could just
completely fall apart i mean i just got
to go for it right yeah
all right that's just gonna have to be
this is our reality
it's definitely thickened up more than i
planned does this look as elegant as i
would have liked
no but it's gonna taste good i hope it's
you know it's rustic so i look over and
claudette is just making this majestic
rainbow it's beautiful it has all these
colors i might be in trouble it looks
like this set
oh look at that
hey i'm shocked
we have clovers those are cute
trying to get some height somewhere so
maybe if i can stand these clovers up
right now i'm going to make my fruit
rainbow and the first thing i'm going to
do is raspberries it's like a race
against time right now because the heat
in this room so we're going pineapple
now i'm gonna put on my kiwis i'm just
gonna paint these little gold coins gold
now i'm gonna place my gold coins like
if my leprechaun just gave no care in
the world to where they were going but
it also helps me kind of hide my little
imperfections and some of the stuff
again i'm trying to get all the height
and drama that i can get so if i don't
win for taste i win for drama for drama
i need more drama in my dish i wasn't
even thinking about drama
my rainbow doesn't look dramatic it
absolutely does it looks cute it looks
better than most things on my plane
ready for the last thing
i'm gonna spin sugar when you're doing
spin sugar you're basically making a
caramel so it's just sugar water and
some corn syrup where is that spatula
interesting and you put your spatula in
right away that's how bad was that
i is that bad i wouldn't put the spatula
back in when someone who's been on top
chef tells you not to stir your sugar
you don't do it and i will never do it
again
sugar is hygroscopic children
sugar absorbs any moisture around it so
it will do it by itself you don't have
to actually mix it this is at 275 right
now um i basically have one shot at this
so i'm gonna do it this is gonna get
everywhere guys sorry they're clouds
they're not as golden as i wanted them
and i think i should have let it go like
a little darker but then you run the
risk of it going to the hard candy so
there are clouds
there we go
cheesecake rambo's on clouds are done i
am done yours looks great you feeling
good
yeah
high fives no panic
you want me to drop it nope sorry never
mind
mental high five go let's go see what
gianna thinks
this is my second time on the show what
i learned the first time is don't go at
it like a chef go at it like a kid and i
wanted the wow factor i wanted her to
gasp i really am into this dish it's not
something that is
chef forward it's something that's
playful my two favorite parts are the
shamrocks and the gold coins and i
really think that gianna's gonna like
them too i'm feeling really good about
my dish i think she's gonna love the
cheesecake with the fruit on top i think
she's absolutely gonna love the honey
chicken with the crunchy toasted coconut
under it the flavors are there it is a
really yummy dish and i'm excited for
her to try it
[Music]
a dish for my coins
oh that looks
something these must be the clovers
my honey chicken
they remembered
these like the little shoe things she
knew that those weird clunky things were
shoe prints
that was satisfying
that's amazing
it's like a fruity crunchy
sweet like piece of cake
i love it yes so she ate some of
cheesecake and then she ate some more
and then she eats more that's when i
feel the trouble i've seen this before i
think it's like where you take like
sugar and like roll it i can't believe
gianna knows how to spin sugar like has
she done this before is she doing it a
lot
feels like a cloud
[Music]
i like it my honey chicken i believe
it's supposed to be the gold piece i am
thrilled
perfect as always perfect as always
[Music]
it's coconut
i like it
i'm not really digging that
i really like the shamrocks
i like everything else except for the
shame rocks oh
she is not liking the quesadilla dare i
say hates it i like quesadillas but it
just
doesn't
yeah
i love everything on the dish i like the
rainbow the best
[Music]
now this
looks fancy i love the rainbow the
clouds i can definitely see that the
footprints i feel like they just
oopsies i feel like
i feel like they look like dots not
really footprints that's exactly how she
drew them
okay i think it's a shortbread lemon
cookie has a little bit of lemon in it
nope no lemon
i like it
jenna loves the coins
this is a marshmallow
perfect as always she's loving how sweet
claudette's dish is and that's making me
concerned
shamrock time
doesn't really have any taste so she's
throwing a little shade on my shamrock
cookies
that's the beauty of being a kid is you
can use your hands even if i don't win i
at least made it fun for her
i'm a marshmallow these are all
different colors but they all taste the
same my flavor strategy might be working
i really like this like lemon
crumble theme dabbah say that again
lemon cookie thing madaha and i like
this coin i have everything i didn't
really like this cookie i have
absolutely no confidence
in my dish
just because of how many bites she took
out of katie's i don't want to jinx it
but i think i might win this time
hello hello whoa how was it it was great
i loved it
sugar
so you have to choose
which one did you like better the
rainbow fruit cake or the pastel rainbow
the pastel rainbow
[Laughter]
[Music]
they never win anything to you
tada
this is huge i'm happy that caught out
one because she's lost before and so
anyone who's lost before i i do want
them to get a win including myself i
thought katie had in the bag but i'll
take this every time i lose i learn
something i'm coming back to win next
time dem go
you